اذا هلكشر السوداني عن انيابه في ايامه
الاولى للرئاسه الحكومه ان ما يجري ليس
الا تنفيذنا لخطابه الاصلاحي والوطني
المؤشرات الاوليه تشير الى غير ذلك بل
تذهب الى ما هو اخطر تنفيذ اجنه الاطار
التنسيقي الموالي لايران بينما هناك من
يراقب ذلك بالسلط مغلق من التيار الصدري
الصامت الغائب او الغائب الغاضب صحيح انه
انسحب من العمليات السياسيه لكنه لا زال
يملك الادوات لتغيير اي معادله سياسيه
وهنا نتحدث عن الشارع الحاضر دوما
يتاهب لاي خطا وربما ينفجر في اي لحظه لكن
هل سيشعل السوداني هذا الفتيل ربما فاصابع
الاطار والملك حاضر الحكومه الجديده
الخطر في تحركاتها وليس في الفساد ولا في
الشارع فحسب تمتد حتى الشمال حيث اقليم
كردستان والملفات العالقه قضيه كركوك
الاكراد يطالبون بضمها والمناطق المتنازع
عليها بين الحكومه المركزيه وحكومه
الاقليم وايضا ملف انتاج وتصدير النفط لدى
رئيس الوزراء يسير في حقل ملغم داخليا
وخارجيا ايضا يتوجب عليه خلقه ذاك التوازن
الضائع بين ارتهانات الارهانات السياسيه
وولاءات خارجيه تؤشر بوصلتها بوضوح نحو
الشرقي نحو ايران وهذا ما يثير التساؤلات
حول علاقات بغداد اقليميه ودوليا واشنطن
التي ترى في الحكومه الجديده شريكا يرى
البعض انها لا ترشرك مع واشنطن ملحه
فالجهات التي شكلتها اعدائها واضح لامريكا
اوضح